Good evening.
Good evening, Paul. Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Good evening, sir.
We'll wait for a few minutes and then we'll,
Okay, so I'm just waiting for sir to join, but
Sir, good evening, sir. I have joined.
Uh, yes, sir. Uh, yeah, sir.
Good evening. Good evening, sir. Sunil, how, how do we go,
Sir? Today? Uh, we
can, we have to start with the RN Okay,
because cnn, we have done even transfer learning at explain
in the last, so R start?
Yeah,
this is the slide deck.
You're also correcting.
Oh, uh, no sir, I, I'm not correcting that slide deck.
Ah, I'm, uh, doing a little bit parallel.
I will show you later, maybe today. You, yes, sir,
No problem.
So good evening all.
Uh, so we will move on to the next, uh,
see after commercial neural networks network.
The next important module, uh,
in deeply line is the recurrent neural networks.
Uh, uh, I, I would like to reiterate that point that no,
if you take conation neural network as a neural network
model or architecture was proposed much earlier
during the era of shallow neural networks itself,
in the same way the recurrent neural networks
or also proposed in the era sha network itself.
However, both these models effectiveness were not able
to be demonstrated, uh,
until the deep learning Iraq came into picture.
There. The basic principle of connection network is in terms
of grid modeling, whereas in the recurrent network,
the purpose is very different.
Uh, if I want to model the, uh,
information present in the sequence sequential data
in more general term, more specific terms,
we can call time series data like thing.
In such cases, uh, at that point of time,
feedforward neural network doesn't come to our help
because they don't assume, you know, there is a,
a need for looking the knowledge from the sequence.
Conation network itself was, um,
developed with a different purpose that is for modeling
data available in a spatial or grid-like structure.
But there are machine learning task where, um,
the sequence knowledge, uh, indeed, um,
uh, is very important for doing certain
predicting something or doing some classification
or any other important task.
There are, that is where they felt there is a need for
coming up with a new neural network architecture, uh,
which can, uh, in the inherent architecture itself,
there is a possibility for capturing
that sequence knowledge.
So that is what, uh, uh, then they're able to demonstrate,
especially in the financial data as well
as the natural language processing, speech processing,
where it all depends on the sequence.
They're able to demonstrate it effectiveness in,
especially in this deep learning era,
using this recurrent neur networks.
Um, so first we need to know what is the need
for such sequence modeling,
and then we will study the basic vanilla version
of the recurrent neural network, what is called, um, uh,
recurrent neural network itself,
and there is something called gated
recurrent neural network.
It's not GRNN, it is mostly called as GRU.
Then, um, long short term memory, uh,
recurrent neural network, and people mostly
call it as LS team.
And these are all unidirectional either left
to right sequence information
or right to left sequence information.
But there are bidirectional recurrent neural networks also
where, uh, in a sequence machine learning task,
I can use the sequence knowledge either from the left till
that point, similarly, from right to that point.
And together I use that knowledge for, uh,
predicting whatever the variable, uh, information
that I'm trying to do.
Of course, there were also some attempts of, uh,
in including that, uh,
sequence knowledge in earlier versions of the new networks.
Those are called time delay networks.
Uh, if possible we can study that,
otherwise we can neglect this part, timely network,
uh, not very relevant.
Then short term sequence information modeling,
and then long-term sequence information modeling,
and finally, attention mechanism,
and we will allow transform network.
So those things, but in the recurrent network in this model,
I think we'll cover up to bidirectional RN and or something.
I think this, I might have told in one
of the earlier sessions, I'm not very sure.
Uh, suppose you, you consider one
of the important task in machine learning
as classification task.
Um, most of the time when we,
we project the classification task,
we say no, the distinction
or discrimination among the classes is in terms of,
uh, different distribution by the feature
of extracts extracted from that classes.
For example, uh, if I, uh, take this
five under three, if I take, uh, you know,
several examples of five and extract the features
and plot, the distribution of the data can be in one color
and three can be in another color.
The fact that there, you know, they're showing different,
uh, distribution inherently, just like visually,
I can make this as five and this has three.
The, in, in the opaque manner,
it'll be a distribution like this.
Now, suppose I have a machine learning model
to model this distribution, then I can build a classified.
So that is how most of the, the projections,
um, is in terms of
distribution of data points or features are very important.
And, uh, people, uh, know did not pay attention
for the sequential order.
But in many tasks, as I mentioned in the opening remark,
the class specific information is in the sequential order.
Many tasks, okay?
Uh, for example, uh,
I think I'm trying for a better example.
I'm not getting, I stuck with these words anyway, just for,
uh, sending out information.
Suppose I take two indie words, KA versus Kamal, okay?
You see in terms of sequence of sounds,
KA is there.
Then here, Kama lies there.
If you see the sequence
of the sounds are same ka, okay?
However, the sequence in which here, aka then ham,
then hams, that is why this ka,
which has a different meaning.
Whereas I take Kala Maah, uh, the car comes,
mark comes, then in the end, law comes.
That's why this is a different meaning.
On the other hand, let just for discussion take,
I take a distribution of cars separately, laws separately
and mass separately,
these two words will have the same distribution.
Okay? Then it is very difficult from
a distribution point of view.
These two words will be confusing.
Alternatively, if I ask a sequence, which sound came first,
which sound came second, which sound came third,
that holds the key for distinguishing
between the two words, okay?
And that is what is called a sequential knowledge, okay?
And that is what in machine,
just like this distinguishing these two words.
Uh, there are many tasks in practice
for classification purpose as a major task.
If you consider the sequential knowledge plays an important
role, okay?
Uh, just, uh, as an example in one
of the mighty course structure, they are given.
Um, so suppose I give this ball position, current position
of the ball and say, can you predict,
uh, in the next instant of time
which direction the ball will move.
In this first image, it's very difficult to predict
because all directions are equally likely.
Okay? Why that, uh, problem is coming, uh,
because I don't have the past knowledge, okay?
Alternatively, suppose you are given this additional
information, a t equal to one.
This was here, T equal to two,
it was here and T equal to three.
It is here T equal to four. Now it is here.
Can you tell me in t equal to five where it go,
it is really easier for you to predict that this will go
to the next position,
and how you're able to say that this ro position, this, uh,
fifth, uh, ball position of the ball will come
because the sequence knowledge is there,
and that is what, uh, know in any
of the machine learning tasks,
which exploit sequence knowledge, they use this for
deciphering or disambiguating or predicting
or classifying using that sequence knowledge.
Okay? And that is what, uh, the significance
of sequence knowledge comes.
It is not, no, we should also, since most
of our explanation is based on distribution,
there's a bias in our mind, um, that no,
or mostly majority of the tasks are distribution only
as some minority cases, sequential knowledge.
It's not the case sequential knowledge base
or classification systems
or prediction, forecasting anything.
No. They're also equally, uh, important
that like the distribution based methods.
That's what I want to say for all.
If you assume no, what is the need for sequence modeling?
Suppose you are given this first phrase saying
that no dash name is dash, very difficult
for me how to fill this.
Now, the dash after, what word I have to put
after name is, it depends on
what is there in this first dash.
For example, if I know the first dash, my name is,
okay, this is my name is, then I will be able
to predict the following word.
So then I, the, the ambiguity is almost zero here,
my name is, then I'll write my name here.
Then suppose I put that my city in this dash,
then my city name is, it is this that means to say,
to fill up what goes here in this world.
I'm referring to the past sequence of words, uh, one
or more words that will decide what goes into this position.
This is another example of sequential knowledge, okay?
So as I explained the answer in this last, uh,
dash position, depends on the previous words in
the sequence, okay?
So, uh, uh, you know, it is not that, no, I'm
invariably just guessing some words there.
Uh, the any amount
of guessing doesn't give you anything I should know.
What is that in the first previous word?
Then only I can put the word there. Okay?
On answer only depends on what the sequence
of passwords are, okay?
So you see how we have been trying as a human brain
to exploit this sequential knowledge, okay?
And people felt if I want
to bring solutions using deep learning models to deal
with the sequential knowledge,
we should also have architectures to capture.
See how I am saying easily able
to write my name is immediately I'm able to write my name
because the sequence knowledge my name is, is
making me to predict
and write the, what is the word going there.
So that is how we have been trying to exploit
that sequence knowledge.
Then how to mimic the same using deep learning models.
So that is what we are trying to see,
even in case of speech.
Also, it is there, for example,
any word when you are listening
and, uh, uh, the meaning that you are arriving at,
maybe at the last word, uh, it depends on
what is the previous words are there, okay?
For example, recently, um, I, in one context,
I was, uh, telling a word from English language.
If I take no, uh, I will say I want
to book a flight, okay?
I want to book a flight.
The second sentence, I will say, I want to read a book.
I want to book a flight, versus I want to read a book.
What is the difference between the, the same word book?
I'm using the meaning of the word.
A book is completely changing based on the sequence
of words, which are in the phrase, which are there.
I want to book a flight versus I want to read a book.
And that is what is the, the, the sequence knowledge
of neighboring words is changing.
The whole meaning of the word book that we are trying
to decipher, then, okay, that is the power
of the sequential knowledge.
Similarly, we have all done this text summarization.
I do, you're being given some say 200 words, uh, uh,
passage, and you have to read
and summarize into say, 25 words passage.
And essentially when you have to summarize, you have
to capture the gist
and keep the gist in 25 words, what is that?
We, do you read all this knowledge When you,
you're reading this sequentially,
you are seeing no from first sentence to last sentence
how the information is evolving
and how the summary is coming based on that.
You write it the sequence,
in the sequence knowledge you are,
and you are able to compress from say, 200 words to 25 words
because of you're able to exploit the sequence knowledge,
comprehend the information, and put it there.
So I'm just trying to see, telling you, telling you people
that no, there are a lot of scope,
and especially in the current era, when we see the benefit
of, uh, good performance
by natural language processing system
or speech processing system, uh, can be mainly attributed to
how we have exploited this.
Modeling the sequence knowledge in the deep learning model,
including your transform knowledge
and generat generated way tools, whatever we are seeing,
whatever generative tools you are using
for literature review seminar,
they're all inherently based on the knowledge for,
if I consider a task like speech recognition, I have input,
X is a speech signal
and the output wise, the sequence of, uh, recognized words,
sequence of recognized words, okay?
And I listen to the speech signal,
I'll write out the sequence of words what I have read,
and that is what I'm decoding the sequence knowledge in the
speech and, uh, giving the sequence knowledge
in the return word.
Same way, video processing input X is a sequence of frames
of video and output.
Y is, and action depicted that Mr.
Say, when I'm watching the video, inherently,
my cognitive system follows with the time, the sequence
of events that are being developed at the end of
that one shot, I'm able to, um, uh, know,
uh, understand what is being said in that shot.
Same way you can do speech to speech translation,
sentiment classification, emotion classification.
You can go on enumerating like this.
There are many tasks in practice which we use
as humans regularly for, uh, uh,
exploiting the sequence knowledge,
and that is where there is a need for
dedicated architectures for sequence modeling.
Okay? So, uh, now,
now these examples will I think, uh, convince enough for all
of you that there is a need for coming up
with sequence modeling approaches.
So any questions or doubt up to this point?
Any of you?
Um, Yes,
Sequence knowledge versus past knowledge, right?
So if you can, if I, if I have to, I'm just trying
to understand the wonderful difference between the, like,
like it's a, if it's a sequence of events
or within an event, it's like, um,
I, I'm, I'm just trying to articulate my question.
That's a beautiful question.
See, past knowledge can be
either based on sequence
or based on, it may not depend on the sequence also, okay?
Right. Uh, uh, past knowledge looks equivalently.
It is not same as sequence knowledge. Okay?
Past knowledge can be, uh, know, uh, which is based
around some distribution also.
Okay? Or you just remember the name
of a person looking at the, uh, face,
Right?
That is a past knowledge,
but just to recall the name of the person,
you are not following some sequence there, okay?
Whereas when I say sequence name, my name is, uh,
my name is prana, I will type this word prana
because what is said in the past is the word my, okay?
And this sequence knowledge also can be past
knowledge, okay?
In the, in the sense the post knowledge is a super set off,
which encompasses the sequence knowledge also.
Okay? Yeah. Awesome, sir. I think that that, uh, helps.
That example that you gave, like my name is, uh, something,
so it, it is a direct reference to
a previous word in the sales.
Ah,
Yes. Yeah.
Okay.
So what it says is, when I come to the sequence knowledge,
um, preserving the order in the given
sequential data is important.
For example, just for, you know, simplicity sake,
uh, for I, um,
say the word coming at time, T equal
to one, I call it as w one word coming at time, T equal
to two, call W2, and so on say N word.
In the current time, I have WEN as the current word,
and is the time instant I'm standing.
Now, the, um, if I want
to really decipher the message, given
I should say W one should be placed at the position of time,
T equal one W to be placed at the place time T equal to two,
and so on, w to be placed at time t equal to y.
If I want to get the same meaning that is there,
you cannot jumble up the words.
If you jumble up the words, it,
it may become nonsensical phrase
or it may give something else.
Okay? So I just know I want to book a flight versus I want
to read a book, okay?
In the same way, what it sequence modeling says is
you should preserve the order in which the data is being
generated in the sequence, and
after preserving the order, then you should develop, uh,
models which can, uh, capture that underlying sequential
order, the underlying order.
And once you capture that order,
that is the training process.
The training process is to capture the
inherent underlying order
or sequential order so that during testing,
when I get such data, I will try
to predict the underlying sequence
that is there in the given, um, uh, phrase.
Based on that, I will be able to predict
what is this sentence,
or, oh, I can be able
to contribute com comprehend what is being said.
Okay? So that is where in the sequential
modeling techniques, uh, you should, uh,
your goal is to model that
during training model the underlying sequence knowledge.
That is what the model captures.
It doesn't capture the seek distribution.
It captures the underlying sequence knowledge.
And once that model learns that use, that learned knowledge,
uh, during the testing stage to
decode the underlying sequence knowledge from the testing
data, for example, assume
that I'm modeling the underlying sequence knowledge I'm
capturing for different phrases, text phrases.
So during testing, suppose somebody, one time I get, I want
to read a book, another time I get, I want to,
um, book a flight.
So I don't know which one that has come.
Now I want to recognize and comprehend that message.
I have to put it to the model,
and it'll decode what is being said that is inherently
by the sequence knowledge.
So that is what, uh, we are to appreciate. Okay,
Sir? One question
here. Sorry to interrupt. Yes, yes.
So for the test data, if we reverse the sequence in
that case, it it'll able to a notify. No,
It'll not, because the, when you reverse the sequence,
that is a totally different, uh, sequential order.
That's why the order is important.
Order is important, yes. Yeah.
Which, which came first?
That will be in the first position. That is how it is,
Yes.
And the another part,
the biggest problem are stumbling block.
They came up with, okay, fine, we understand how
to know there is a significance for sequence modeling.
How do I do that? But now suppose, you know,
suppose you have four to five words phrase
or something, it's okay, I will do some, just for example.
Now suppose if it is a hundred words sequence, uh,
as the length of the sequence increases,
how do I build a model?
I can't go on, uh, you know,
putting every position there is a model separately, then,
then getting that much data to try
and everything becomes a problem.
You, and also, uh, more than that, the important point is,
especially in this time series data, sequential data,
what happens is for the same information,
the sequence length may change.
Of course, in a fixed text word, it is same.
For example, if I take speech signal, I may say,
I want to read a book.
If I record the speech signal, that word say it comes
to 1.5, second, next time I want
to say I want to read a book.
That might come in only one second.
So now how do I match the sequences of different length?
There's nothing like a fixed thing always
happens in the time series data.
There are variable length.
If there are variable length, how do I put model for
that much time duration, unfold
and unfold, that becomes a problem.
So that is where people felt the, the first problem.
Any model that is coming from taking care
of the sequential knowledge
or training, learning the sequential knowledge, um,
uh, I will, uh, no, uh, I will be able
to, uh, I will be able to deal with sequences
of different length for the same information.
There's a possibility that for the same information,
the sequences from one, one example
or one instance to the next instance, maybe
of different length, I should be able to handle that.
I can't have a fixed length of things.
So that is where that was one
of the inherent characteristics.
When they have to come up with an architecture, they have
to come and, uh, of course
they, before this neural network model came,
there are non neural network model based on probability
that are called a sarcastic models,
well known we call hidden Marco models.
We just for illustration, again, it is not
that no only neural network models,
based models are the first models to give.
There were stochastic models like hidden Marco models,
which had, uh, uh, no challenges, uh,
which demonstrated the way to model the sequence knowledge,
at least inspired by that.
These deep learning models are neural network models came up
with different, the first well known architecture is a
recurrent neural network and it's variance like gated
recurrent neural LS team.
But what is important is understanding the working principle
of recurrent neural networks is most crucial.
Once you understand that rest of the things can be, uh,
you know, understood easily, uh,
because these are variants of the to,
but when we are understanding these RNs, what we have
to understand is first thing is what is the problem
with the existing, uh, uh, feed forward neural network?
Why it is not, uh, be able to model the sequence knowledge.
Then how, uh, we can, uh, modify that
to model the sequence information.
That is first point we have to understand.
The second point is how do I deal
with the varying lens sequence knowledge, uh,
in any neural network architecture?
Those are the two points that we have to understand.
Once you understand that SGU LSTM are just variance of that,
we can try to understand, okay?
Then time delivery networks is another architecture,
which we'll look into it.
Uh, I think, uh, uh, no, you consider no
why recurrent neur neural space, a significant role.
You consider name recognition task,
and, um, my goal is to recognize the proper names
or proper nouns in a given text,
but the position is not imported in
the name recognition task.
This fruit is apple. Apple is a fruit name.
Suppose if it is there,
apple is coming in different positions,
but for me, the position is not important for me.
Wherever it comes, I want to spot, okay?
So we need to be able to develop a model to read a sentence
and extract the fruit name.
That is also can be, you know,
sequential modeling technique.
Uh, so this apple is the relevant piece
of information, whichever.
Um, for on the other hand, no, suppose I train a, uh,
fix it a multi-layer perceptron to process fix it length.
This is not a fixed length, okay?
Separate MLP for each position, say this word,
I will have a separate MLP fruit as a separate MLPs
and fl, they're very, very trivial example to say,
but in, if I want to approach this by MLP, what I do is,
for a very word, I will have a separate MLP
and try to model some brute force way of telling.
Then what will happen is I need to have, you know,
this ML multilayer perception will not work for this,
because first word in this case is this.
In other cases, apple. So that becomes a problem.
On the other hand, if I have a recurrent neural network,
I can use the same one architecture
to handle this name recognition task.
So that is what is, uh,
the advantage of, uh, neural network.
Uh, see, recurrent neural network comes into picture.
Uh, of course, these are some examples.
Fix window model long term, you know,
if I take a fixated window time window,
which will have a limited, uh, time streak.
For example, if I have a fixer link this morning,
I took my cat for a walk, okay?
Uh, given these, predict the next word.
For example, this morning I took my cat four A,
then you say no walk or something, that prediction.
So, um, on the other hand, uh, suppose if I take,
um, um, if,
if I have a fixed window, which has a limited is three,
you can't model the long-term dependencies there.
So that is where this sar n
and variance, you can also, uh, have an advantage over
field for network in terms of modeling the, um, long-term.
So what I'm trying to say is even if you say, no,
I will use a fixed window, always, I have no problem,
I will try to model F and N, but you cannot use that fix f
and n for a long-term dependency.
For example, uh, if I have say six words
or seven words, fix dependency
and chop off this to say only six or seven words.
Suppose, um, I say, uh,
I grew up, uh, but I now live in Boston.
I speak fluent. Suppose if you are miss this long-term
dependency of France is where I grew up here in the fluent,
you may guess Boston means I may be using English, okay?
I may write English here
because I am missing that long-term dependency.
So the long-term dependency influences what,
what is the actual word, should go here.
And such things are difficult to be modeled
by a fixed window, uh, new networks like feedforward,
new networks, that that is where, uh,
people thought about know this
recurrent new network like architectures
will be useful for us.
And also randomizing and applying feed.
See if you see Feedforward network, if you recall,
I think sir would've explained while training the MLP
or something, you know, you have all the feature
vectors, you randomize the feature vectors
apply each feature vector in a random manner.
Okay? Um, so
accordingly, no, you completely don't have to keep track
of the sequence knowledge
because that is based on the distribution.
Okay? Uh, so
accordingly, the basic training process
of feedforward network is not suitable
for your sequence modeling.
On the other end, you say no parallel input,
parallel output, I will put no,
I will input include the increase the input layer
and put a longer sequence lens.
But that cannot be, uh, useful
because parallel palp configuration may be
alternative because input
and output, it can be a very large dimension
when you have large dimension, rather than general learning
and generalizing, it may go for memorizing.
Okay? And, uh, the other one is,
it is not possible.
No. If you have input an out vectors of different length
of different example, that is a more practical
challenge that we'll face.
So essentially these are just to list few cases that
essentially what the nutshell, what what is, um,
uh, in going to be inferred here is,
um, you will, um,
traditional feed for our neur network.
Their philosophy of development of them training
and using in practical setting are totally not useful
for when I go for sequence modeling.
That is where it warrants a new sequence modeling
neural architecture.
So that is the meaning that's, uh, for example, if I take,
what are the limitations of sequence modeling,
you need a fixed window length, uh,
which is not possible in case of sequence modeling.
It cannot model a variable length long term dependency.
So no feed for network cannot model,
cannot model the word order, cannot share the parameters.
So all these things, because if I take a feed for network,
I'm training, all weights are unique.
You can't share those weights
because they, they carry the weightage for
that particular link in the neural network.
So because of these, all these challenges, uh,
you know, people, uh, uh, felt no, there is a need
for coming up with a new architecture for sequence model.
So, which can handle what is that, uh, wishlist
for a new architecture,
the model which can handle variable length window,
which can model, uh, variable length, long-term dependency,
which can preserve the world order,
which can share the parameters across the time or sequence.
All these things are relevant requirement for, uh,
a new architecture that they have to evolve.
And that is where they came up with
what are called a recurrent neural network,
as the name itself indicate, the word recurrent means
repeating or sharing across different sequence positions
just to, uh, know, uh, show
how a transition happened from feed forward neural network
to recurrent neural network.
Um, suppose if I take a feed forward network,
which you have seen as a part of your, uh,
feedforward network, you have input layer, output layer,
and one or more done layers are there just
to see a simplified structure for, uh, this one.
Suppose for a given position,
I model the information in the given position,
say using a feed for our network,
and then another position, I will put one more feed
for our network, another position, I'll put one more feed
for our network pictorially,
it becomes very clumsy to show that.
So just for a simplified notation,
this whole layer input layer is, uh,
collapsed into one symbol of this color, showing
that there's an input layer.
Similarly, there can be one hour more than layers all have
been collapsed to make it as one symbol to
represent one hour more than layers.
Similarly, output layer, entire layer is given
by one dot showing that output layer,
because this symbol which is there below this,
that is a typical symbol we use
for recurrent neural network.
You should not be confused with the, no.
How does this perform as a neural network?
Because input node, output node simple on one neuron,
you are kept just from a notation point of view,
what we have done is, uh, in the literature, they collapse
that and represent like this.
Now again, so now the bigger structure,
you collapse into a single line,
but again, for each position, you go on putting them again,
the sequence length increases.
Can I further compress that for that purpose?
What they did is instead of horizontal, the flip vertical,
this network, when you flip vertical,
then you can map like this, this input X.
And so this symbol, that arrow which is coming back
indicates you are putting that
fit for network at different positions.
That means to say I share the parameters across different
positions, and that is indicated by this, okay?
It is not the feedback.
The past values, position values are available
while modeling in the current po.
For example, time three equal to two, I have an input a x,
and I want to compute the output at time t equal to two.
This output in the sequence modeling technique not only
depends on the current input,
but also depends on the previous output.
How is the previous output
that is stored here in this AutoMark
that weight along this link,
since this is repeating this wait for
sequence knowledge is repeating, let they call it
as a recurrent neural network.
So, uh, maybe I will, um, stop it here.
If you have any questions, I will take it up.
Otherwise, Sunil, we want to,
Sir, how, uh, yeah, ish?
Yes, sir. How keep track of track
of the previous word? Yes, sir. Correct.
That, that I will tell in the next session.
Um, yes, but up to this point, you should, uh, uh,
this one maybe quickly, I will just mention that point.
This is what we are going to discuss.
C at the time key, the,
the past value information that I'm going to update, no,
that depends on what was the world state value,
previous value, which is fed back from the previous time
instant, and the current input together, we'll store
that sequence knowledge in this ro
and that will, that is in the form of weight parameters.
Yep. Okay? Yes.
Yeah, we'll discuss that later in the next, yeah, sure.
Thank you. Yeah. Any questions for me,
Sir? This is
ish, sir, if possible, can you like, uh,
we re-explain a bit
of the arrow part in the second diagram? Ah,
Yeah. So
I, I will do that,
but you, if you are not able to still,
you have an ambiguity, don't worry.
Uh, in the following classes, it'll be clear.
What I wanted to say is suppose, assume
that there are three words in world.
One, I'm putting one feet for network world, two position,
I'm putting another fit for network.
What are the three position?
I'm putting another fit for network
looks very big horizontally when I, the,
you imagine this network is being
repeated in three positions.
Now writing that one is difficult.
That's where no simplified thing is.
I'm collapsing those neurons in a given layer and even one
or more done layer, also collapsing into one symbol
representing all the hidden layers.
And this is a simple line.
Now still, I have to replicate this horizonal line of three,
three things to indicate the position.
On the other hand, suppose, uh,
what is the purpose of the second position?
What is the purpose of second po?
Third position is I'm ordering them in that way, that
while computing the output at the second position,
I will also make out
of some information from the first position.
And what is that information required that is being computed
and stored in this link,
and that is sufficient for me to compute the output
of the second instant.
And while doing the output, I'll also compute the feedback,
not feedback, this, uh,
past knowledge which will be required
for the next position when I go to the next position.
This RO mark indicates
that you are bringing the sequence knowledge from the
previous position that is available
and the current input is available.
Combine them to get
you, don't worry.
No, we, we, we see this equation will when we dis agate,
we'll come to know in the next session.
Yes, sir.
Thank you, Sir. I have a quick question.
Uh, just curious, uh,
can a sequence model work without remembering the past?
No, the, the DNA of A sequence modeling is, uh,
the sequence knowledge without that?
No. Uh, then there's no memory in the sequence. Knowledge.
The memory is a very important aspect.
Uh, it cannot work without a, uh, uh, you are
post knowledge means, I'm assuming sequence knowledge.
Uh, yes. Are You meaning, uh,
if it is a post knowledge, a sequence, yes.
Uh, meaning that, uh, is it possible, uh,
to predict the next, uh,
output based on the current input only
and not based on the past inputs or outputs?
Hmm. Yeah.
So see, of course there are attempts for that,
but the, not in this RRNN,
but in domestic model, the Marco change, people say
the output depends only on the present input
post output we have, we don't have to worry remotely three,
but what it means is when you're making that assumption
that post whatever single bit information
that we are collecting up to the point
that in intern has all that knowledge put up to that point.
Mm, yes. If that assumption is valid,
then you don't require the post sequence knowledge.
Got it. Thank you, sir.
Sir, one quick one.
Was this the predecessor of LSTM because of the memory, ah,
The predecessor, the first version,
vanilla version is this RNN.
Then they found that RNN cannot
still do a good job for long, long-term dependency.
That is where they brought in the team to take care of the,
uh, long-term dependency.
Right, sir. And one more thing, sir.
Last, uh, Sam, we used to have NLP,
and in that we read about some stochastic way
or some kind of rule-based, uh, grammatical,
um, predictions.
So those were the stochastic models
you were talking about? Mm-hmm.
Correct. Correct. There is one type of stochastic models,
there's Marco models,
which I told is also a well known
stochastic model. Alright?
Okay. Thank you, sir. Thank you.
Okay, Sunil?
Yes, sir. I'll just take over second, second,
Stop sharing.
So, um, my, my, uh, plan is to just, uh, uh, almost, uh,
repeating the same thing what we have been discussing,
what SIR has explained so far, maybe
with some visualization, with some examples so that
you'll have better understanding that, okay, how this, uh,
uh, RNN what is this?
RNN, how, and what is the problem with the NN
with the sequential data it solves?
Okay, so
let's start with this slide.
So I'll just take you through some, uh,
some real time examples
and with that, we'll see that if we are, you are able
to understand this in, in better world.
So, uh, but so far the, the way we have seen the data,
we have seen two types of data.
If you can recall from our earlier interactions and demos
and all, we have either seen the tablet data
or, uh, with the NENN,
we mostly talked about the Tableau data itself,
or we talked about with the CNN,
the image data, the grid-like data.
So we talk about this tabular data.
Uh, this is how say it is.
It's a student placement data where you have one input
as a CGP and other input as IQ of the student.
Third and put, uh, third, third, uh, column is say
that the placement, uh, yes
or no, so that these three are the columns
or some other time, you may also try to find
what is the prediction of having the placement.
So what I'm trying to say here is
if you'll suppose build this, uh, build a neural network
for this kind of data, it'll look something like this
where you have the cz PA iq, also placement also, right?
And then you are trying to do what is the prediction?
Whatever is the prediction. That doesn't matter here.
But then I'm saying that these three are my inputs
and the prediction, the last column is my output.
And suppose you will build one fully connected network,
the a NN, it'll look something like that.
Now, one thing, what why I say today, non-sequential data,
because the, here, when you build this network, this, this,
a NN, you try to feed the data, uh,
we always feed the data wise, right?
So we have three inputs.
That's why we have the three, three features.
That's why we have, uh, fixed air as three inputs.
Suppose you would have four inputs.
Uh, we would have fixed air, uh, four feature,
then we would've fixed air, four inputs and so on.
So input dimension in the a NN is, is, uh,
is equivalent to, to your number of features,
what you have in your tablet data.
Okay? Now, why do I say it as non-sequential?
Just consider this case.
Suppose I, I, here I'm feeding it as CGP as a first input,
and then IQS second input and placement as third input.
Now, suppose if I change this order
or somehow I'll first, uh, I'll,
I'll put here iq, I'll put here.
Uh, CGPA or placement will come in the middle.
What will happen to the network?
Do you see that any, any, any change will happen in terms
of the output, in terms of the prediction, the answer is no.
Right? Because all these are values.
Some values 7.1, say here, 71, here it is, yes or no.
Now that, that are connected with some set of weights
and all these inputs are connected
with all the neurons here, right?
So if you see that how much it may impact your output,
it'll have hardly any impact.
Obviously, I understand that once you change their
positions, maybe the weights,
what you have initialized here will slightly, it'll change.
Okay? Here, uh, might the weight will, will,
might be something else,
and here might be the something else.
So if the input placement will go here, it'll now connect it
with these set of weights rather than these set of weights.
Okay? Now that is the change,
but ultimately you have to do the back propagation
and you have to get the output.
So, but the way this, this hidden layer, it is going
to receive the data, it is almost same.
Obviously weight will have slight impact,
but this, it, it is almost same.
So the order of these features doesn't matter.
Okay? Order of these feature doesn't matter.
Why, because it's a non-sequential data
and that, that, that doesn't matter, right?
Whether my IQ the first column
or CTP is second column, I mean that hardly matters for,
for even for the human being
or even for the neural network, okay?
And we treat each of these network as independent features,
and that's how this a and n works.
So no dependency in the row in the features order
of row does not matter, right?
Even the rose, uh, order of a rose does not matter, right?
Even the columns you can feed in the se different,
different sequence, right?
But this type of data, we said
non sequential data, okay?
Makes sense right? Now,
let us talk a little bit about the sequential data, okay?
Now this is one example of the sequential data,
like stock price data, where we have four columns.
Say that I have a date, I have an open, uh, like say
that there is a stock which opens at this price,
and uh, the highest in that day, uh, uh, was this price
and the close at this particular price,
the same stock on the next day opens at this price
where it got closed.
Then highest it got up to 1 0 3 0.75,
and it closed it at this, this price,
obviously in the next state will open at the same price,
uh, in this sequence, right?
And then it will close at certain price.
You see that there is some kind of sequence.
Every row is now connected with the earlier row.
Somehow there is some kind of information which is flowing,
some kind of information which is being flow.
That is, so you can see that this is sequence,
row wise sequence, obviously here, the date,
data wise sequence, you can see that,
and that that really matters when
it comes to the stock prices.
And that's how you can do some kind of, uh, uh, predictions,
some kind of assumptions, and you know that now, um, then
accordingly, you can take a call that whether I have
to invest in the stock or not,
or whatever, it's, so observations are time ordered.
You can see the date wise
and you cannot shuffle the rose just like that, okay?
If you'll shuffle the rose, then your data, I mean the, the,
the main, main pattern in the data is lost.
And if then you will shuffle the row, give it to the network
to understand the pattern, I mean,
the network will struggle, it may not give you the correct
patterns that, okay, what will be the next day opening
or highest or closing, whatever, it's okay.
So the past prices influences the future prices.
Now, this type of data, when you have, this is known
as the sequential data.
This is called the sequential data.
There is one such example of the sequential data, right?
Another example, what was giving, uh,
that the text data text is a very good example
of the sequential data, okay?
Um, there can be other data also,
like speech is another sequential data.
Like you, when you record the,
the same meeting was being recorded.
It is very important that what what has been told earlier,
then the later, and then at the last.
Otherwise, if you don't maintain this,
if you start seeing anything from the last
and you shuffle the, you can say that the, uh, uh, the,
the video with a different, different, uh, timestamp
and all, then you will not understand the whole whole, uh,
uh, just stop that particular video, right?
Similarly, the video is also a sequence of frames. Okay?
So here, uh, the text for
that matter is also a sequence of frame.
And this is a very good example of the sequential data.
And we are also going to stay with this particular data
for our, uh, for our more, uh, understanding
of the RNs, okay?
So when I will talk about the RN and L-S-T-M-G-R-U
and so on, uh, our examples, uh, what, uh, what, uh,
I will give you will be more from the text angle,
because with the text, we can, uh, we can, uh,
understand it in a better way.
But the same thing applies for any se of data for
that matter, okay?
Whether it is speech data, whether it is a sequence of, uh,
uh, frames, right?
So you can apply that, that knowledge there,
but with the text, it, it, it, it, you will be able
to understand it in a better way.
Okay? So now say that we have one sequence
of data as this sentence.
We are in LLM class.
Say that there is an LM class
and we are now learning about the l lm.
Okay? Now suppose I have to feed this data
to the network, to the neural network.
And so far as we have learned about only a n, N and CNN.
Now I'm giving you the example of the a NN, okay?
So in the a NN, what is the idea?
A NN you have to first decide that
what will be the dimension of your input that
how many inputs you are going to feed to the network.
So this layer is your input layer,
and then in the next layer you have three neurons,
and the last layer, you have one neuron.
So that this is structure. What I have to follow.
So first of all, I have to decide
how many inputs I have to feed.
Now, as per the text
or I for the sentence, I have five words.
We are in l, LM class, five words I have.
But as we understand, you can't feed the word as it is.
So we understood earlier also
that we can convert the words easily into the
one hot vector form.
And you can see here in this particular table
for the word we, this is the one hot vector
where first index is high rest.
All indexes are zero.
And for the word R, second index is high,
for the word in third index is high, and so on.
So every, every word is represented as vector
with five values.
So every word has five values
and how many words we have in this sentence?
Five. Now suppose I have to feed the sentence,
whole sentence together or the whole sentence as an input.
I need five such vectors, five such one hot vector
to be stacked on top of each other in the vertical way.
In the vertical way. That's why this
is shown here like that.
So first five is representing we,
next five values are representing are these, these values.
One hot vector value. Next five values are representing in
next five values are representing l, l, m.
And last five values are representing class.
So together, how many inputs we have together,
we have 25 inputs altogether
because I need to feed the complete sentence
as an input to the network.
So what will happen in the case of NNI need
to define that, okay?
What is my input, uh, input, uh, uh,
dimension for this mural network?
Here it is 25 because I have five words.
Each word is represented by five inputs.
Five, five, uh, five numbers as a one hot vector
stacked each, each e each other on top of each.
So we have 25 values going parallelly
as an input to this network.
And then we do some processing here as we do, uh, for,
for any neuron here, here, here.
And finally we get the output. Okay?
So this is what is the case when you will feed the
sequential data like we are in LLM class
to the artificial neural network.
Okay? Now see the problem with this, uh, this kind
of a NN Now say that in the last example I had one,
one sentence where I had a five words,
but there is a possibility
that I have a next sentence which I have to process,
where we have only three words where, where the sentence say
that we study ML machine learning.
I have only three words here.
Maybe one more sentence I have in my corpus where it say,
today we study neural networks, five words.
Second, here we have deep learning is
powerful, only four words.
So now what will happen, uh, what will happen in this case
that see this dimension is very important,
this input a neural network in and what you're designing.
So for the first sentence, for the first sentence here,
you say that I have only three words.
Now say that every word here is represented
by five dimensional, one hot vector, just for, for the case.
Then what will happen, five here, five year,
five year total 15 inputs you up to feed
to the neural network.
But in this case where you have five words,
five into 5, 25 inputs, you have
to feed in the next sentence also 25 inputs,
and the next sentence, 20 inputs.
So three words. So how many inputs?
Three into V and V is a five.
Just for the example, like I've shown here, here V is five.
So each word is represented by five dimensional,
one hot vector, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 values.
Okay? So we, I'm representing here by five.
Obviously in this case it'll be more,
but just for the simplicity,
that's why I'm representing here by V.
So if it is five, then here the input dimensional will be 15
here, 25 here, 20.
So we the vocabulary size,
so each sentence has a different length here.
One hot size depends on the vocabulary.
So if your vocabulary size is 10, then we will be 10,
it'll be 30, 30, 30, okay?
Total input dimension changes with the sentence length here.
The total input dimension is three to V here in here,
five V here, four, we, so for every sentence,
my input length is changing.
Input dimension is changing.
And that's why this question I, I have written here,
have you ever seen a neural network
where the input dimension changes for every row
or every input in your corpus?
The answer is no. You can't do that one, right?
So if you have a given corpus, if you have to, uh,
if you have a data, you first have to define that, okay?
How many inputs it is going to accept?
It can be three V, it can be five B, it can be four B,
but it cannot be all the three,
three v also five V also four B.
Also based on the same, uh, based on the sentence length.
It cannot be like that. You have to predefine it,
you can change it, but
that neural network will be different, okay?
So you can't be, you can't have the different number
of inputs as it's shown here for every, uh, every,
uh, sentences in your corpus.
Now, that is the first problem, what I see processing the
text with the ENN,
because text has the varying length, right?
Every sentence will be, will have this,
uh, will have the different length.
You don't know what will be the length
of every sentence in your corpus.
It'll be different, okay?
You can't be keeping the similar length
for all the sentence, right?
I mean, that is not, not possible.
Say that you're taking the example of say that, uh,
flip card reviews, all review has a different length.
Some review, people have written only two words.
Some review, they have written 200 words.
I mean, you can't be having the similar
lens sentence always.
If you take example of X where people post there also,
you see that, uh,
although the maximum number of character is fixed,
but we don't, we can write our own whatever we want
to write it, and then length will vary.
Definitely it is going to vary.
So the nature of the data is like that.
Then if the nature of the data is like that, how will you
create the NN which always accept the fixed length input.
It cannot accept the varying length input.
Now, that is the first problem,
what I see when using the sequential data like text
with ENN,
okay?
So, uh, this is the biggest problem.
One of the problem, I mean, uh, biggest I not say,
but then, uh, there are more problem, which I'm going
to talk next, but with the a NN if you will, uh,
have the text data, this is one of the problems.
So, mismatch, mismatch, input, input,
mismatch problem, okay?
So what fee forward network expect fixed size, input vector,
same number of features for all samples,
but that is not true.
My input length is varying.
So same number of features, I can't, can't,
can't have the same number of features, right?
And, uh, independent processing of each input.
I'll talk about that one, okay? I'll talk about that.
So what text data provides the variable length sequences,
as I said, so fixed input size requirement makes an a NN
unsuitable for text sequences, okay?
You see that, that what is the first problem? Okay?
Now, there can be a quick fix for this particular problem,
quick fix, okay?
I understand that this is the problem,
but there is a, there is a solution for that.
What I can do is in my whole corpus,
I can find what are the maximum length sentence,
what are the maximum length sentence, A sentence
where I have 200 words say that that is a maximum, okay?
Or here I mentioned maximum sentence length
is a hundred a sentence.
Having the hundred words, what I will do is find it,
find the longest sentence in the corpus, okay?
So what I'll do is, anyway, for every word,
I'm representing it by a vocabulary size.
And if I have the hundred words in a maximum length
sentence, I can have say a hundred into V.
That is the dimension for my input.
A hundred into v, V is V depends on your vocabulary size,
which is take shown here as 1000,
but it depends on your vocabulary size.
In your corp say that it is 1000,
1000 unique words you have,
and every word you will represent
as one hot dimension like this.
But only difference would be here.
Here, the one hot dimensional length would be 1000.
1000, okay?
And if suppose you have, uh, a sentence having
a hundred words that is a maximum length
of a particular sentence in your corpus, then
what will be the input dimension?
A hundred into 1000.
Just imagine, just imagine that particular part.
So this is a quick fix.
You can say that, that, uh, for, for a maximum length
sentence, the number of input will be thousand into 100,
which will be this much one like parameters,
one like input length, not parameter one, like input length.
Fine. No, this is fine, this is still fine.
But the problem would be every sentence is
not of the similar length.
Say that some sentence is having only five words,
maximum length is a hundred.
In such case, what we have
to do is we have two add zeros of vectors.
How many vectors?
95 such vectors with all zeros,
because only five words I have in my sentence,
maximum length a hundred based on which I
have defined my input.
So 95 zeros, I will add 95 zeros I'll add.
So this is fine, but after that 95 zeros I'll add.
Okay, now that is also fine. But what is the problem here?
The problem here is it'll massively increase the parameters
and computation as soon I add these many inputs
for every sentence.
How many weights would required here?
One lack in 2, 3, 3 lacks way to be required
to process every sentence in your corpus
because there's a fully connected network, right?
If you have one lag input here, connected
with three neurons in the hidden one, lag into three,
three lacks, weights are required.
Three lacks weights are required with a sentence
where you have a hundred words and three lacks weights are
required where you have sentence with the five words also.
So it is simply a waste of resources
because it, it has now increased the number
of parameter massively computation is going to.
So it is going to be very slow, requires a lot of resources,
wasted of everything.
You can say that. But there is a bigger problem with this.
Now say that we have already processed, uh,
with the hundred, uh, length, size input,
and we have built this neural network training is done.
Say that now.
At the test time, a new sentence come where the length
of the sentence is more than a hundred,
because you don't have any control, right?
That what will be the length of a sentence At the test time,
you don't have any control.
It depends on how the inputs are coming.
Suppose it is more than a hundred,
your whole network will fail
because now you designed your network
to accept only a hundred words.
Somehow you have padded for the less than a hundred words,
sentences, but the problem has come
now it is more than a hundred.
So you can, there's no, instead of a hundred,
I can make 200, I can be 500.
But say that 505, that is the length
of new sentence, what will happen?
Because it can go up to infinity.
That is the upper limit for the length of a sentence, right?
So you can't be building such a bigger network, right?
Just, and then there are a lot, many other problems.
Also, it massively increases the parameters.
Computation is going to take more time, resources and so on.
So this is another problem.
If you quick fix with the zero padding to make all
of your sentence in the corpus
as a equivalent length, this is the problem.
What you will end up with. Okay? Okay.
Now this is another problem.
Now let us talk about the third problem.
This is the third problem. Another problem is
disregarding the sequence information.
We server also talking sometime back.
Now, two problem we have seen.
The first problem is that by
default, A and N cannot take the text as an input
because every sentence is a different differently.
But we can do some quick fix by doing the zero padding,
but it has its own problem.
The third, and I think this is the biggest problem,
I would say that it disregards
the sequence information.
As I was talking here, now, I'll take you back
to this particular slide where I, where I, where I said, say
that there is a one, one row I'm processing
where I have three features, C, G, P, A icon placement.
Suppose I just change their positions. Placement comes here.
C, g, P in second place, IQs third plate, and so on.
Shuffle that one. Instead of passing CG p, IQ
and placement as first, second, third,
I'll change their positions.
What would happen? And we discuss that. Okay?
There might be a slight change in the prediction. Why?
Because the weights here are different, okay?
Connected with each of these input,
but there won't be much impact on overall prediction.
Okay? So now just repeat the same thing here for,
for this, this particular example of text.
We are in LLM class. Now see, this is the sequence.
Now again, we are talking about the sequence.
We are in l, l, M class first.
This is the one hot for V, then one hot for R one, hot
for in LLM class.
Now just suppose as we were trying to do here, changing
of the sequence, let us change the sequence.
Instead of VI, I'll feed l, LM instead of class.
I'll feed R instead of in.
So if, suppose we change the sequence itself.
If change with sequence itself, suppose here,
forget about this neural network.
If we change the sequence here in the sentence,
what will be the result?
Resultant would be a new sequence
and may have altogether different meaning from this
particular sequence altogether.
Different meaning from this se particular sequence, right?
So what is happening here is
when you are feeding all these somehow
by doing the quick fix and all geo padding
and all you're feeding all the words together,
that is still fine, right?
Uh, with those problem, which we have talked,
but while when we are feeding all of them in the same
ly like this, ly like this, then
what is happening is you're losing
that sequence information.
Like it doesn't matter whether V has come first.
LLM has come first, R has come first
or class has come first.
It means if we, we would've fit V here
or class here, it would have, it would've been same,
almost same, obviously slightly.
There might be a change in this way.
But then because we are processing everything ly there,
the non-sequential data did not impact it.
And here, if we process everything ly,
you will see there is a, that there is a some problem.
There is a problem. The problem is you're not able to,
under the network will not be able
to understand the overall context of this particular thing,
the overall meaning of this particular sentence,
of this particular sequence.
So when we are processing everything parallelly,
so at a time I'm processing, we are in,
I'm not saying that first I'll process.
We then r then in, so that I'll have some understanding
that these three words are already processed
before processing the LLM
that I'm not doing everything I'm processing in parallel.
Hence, we are disregarding the sequence information.
So in this case, for when the data is
sequential, it matters.
Earlier case, it did not matter.
Here, here it did not matter when we processed it in the,
in, in the sequence ly,
or we should, we might have changed their orders also.
So order or sequence, uh, order doesn't matter here
because everything we are processing,
every features are independent.
But here it is not like that. It is depending. Okay?
So, uh, our should come after me only.
Now, that is the dependence what we have in the text data.
But we don't care. Uh, we don't process in the same way
how it is, how the data, uh, how the data is designed
or how the data natures how the data nature is, right?
We are processing them in the panel.
Hence, we are losing the sequence information.
We will get some output here, right? But then it'll lose it.
It is not, it has not considered the sequential.
So words converted to one hot vector.
All vectors are flattened, as I said, fed
to the network in one, one shot.
The network does not know which words come first,
which words come later position
and order information is lost.
Okay? So this is the problem.
This is the another problem, what you can say.
So now if I'll summarize, this is the summary slide
that YNN fails for the sequential data.
The first one is the fixed input size.
Because a NN always cannot, uh,
an n naturally cannot help handle the variable in
sequence, as I said earlier.
Also, unless you don't do those, those quick fix problems,
zero padding and all, it cannot, uh, it cannot, uh, take it.
This text cannot be given as an input
because text has variable length, variable length.
And then you see that,
that the neural network always accept ENN always accept the
fixed input size.
That is the first problem. Second loss
of order information as we have seen.
And the third one is if suppose you do some quick fix
with the zero padding
and all making all the sentences in your corpus equal
length, then also there is a problem with respect to the
wasted competition.
Massive, uh, massive parameters, which you have
to train and all those things.
And finally, the poor generalization,
by all doing all those things also it support the test time.
The sequence or the sequence will come
with the land greater than what you have done,
what you did in the train time.
Then whole neural network will fail
and it cannot process that information at all.
So all these are the problems
with the a NN when processing a sequential data like text.
So what do we need? So we need
a network which can handle the variable length inputs.
We don't have to forcefully put the zeros
or we don't have to do the padding,
zero padding forcefully just
to handle the variable length sequence,
which the a NN is trying to do.
That is the first thing which we want with the network.
Second one is I want to preserve the order.
Order is very important to the sequence, right?
And a NN is, and
and fails to maintain that order, we have
to preserve that order somehow.
Third, the parameter was the problem, right?
That it was blowing up like anything, right?
When we were doing the zero padding, uh,
then, uh, it was blowing up.
If we don't do the zero padding.
Also for every input you see here, for every input,
we have a separate set of weights which are connected
with these set of neuros, right?
As you can see here, here, here, also, same thing, right?
For V you have separate set
of weights connected with these three neuron.
For r you have separate set
of weights connected with these three.
So here you have, I suppose you have 25, 25 into 3 75
weights, which is required here
between this input and output.
25 looks so small, I know,
but then when the work vocabulary size will be thousand
and the input sequence will be a hundred, then this,
this is a huge number
of one lag parameter just for one layer.
It's a huge number of parameters without zero padding.
I'm talking about without zero padding. Okay?
So somehow we have to see a network where we can just,
we can minimize the number of parameters also, because, uh,
because you don't have any control on the sequence
of the length, sequence of the length.
So if you take a book,
and if you count, if I have to process the entire book
or say that, or chapter in the books, in the chapter
of the books, you may have 10,000 words maybe,
which you have to process altogether, okay?
Or 5,000 words or 1000 words.
You can't be going with like, okay, 1000 uh,
words and each word is represented
by 1000 dimensional vector.
I mean, you can't process it.
We don't have such a huge resource also. Okay?
So we just have to think about the parameters also,
because now we say that I have
to handle the variable length sequence means I'm aiming,
it doesn't matter how long the sequence would be,
I'm able to handle it.
But then the case where you'll have a hundred words,
thousand words, how will you handle that?
You don't have the computation power
itself, but that is another problem.
We'll see that if you can do some share
of the parameters across all the words.
Across all the words, okay?
And finally, the ma most important, uh, uh, problem,
uh, in order to capture the context was that the network,
the ENN doesn't have any kind of memory so
that it can remember, okay,
what word we have already processed in the past.
For example, when I'm processing LLM,
I want a network which can remember I have already
processed, we are in these three words.
So at the time of LLM, this memory, if I'll have that,
I have already processed, we in, maybe
together we are in LLM will have better meaning rather than
processing L-M-L-L-M in parallel with A VRE
where LLM process, this information doesn't have any context
with this or the word which are coming later.
Okay? So all these things we want with a network, which a
and n fails to give a NN cannot provide all these things,
which is required to process a data like text.
And then the solution is a recurrent neural network.
RNN comes with all these solutions.
All these solutions, okay?
Now, uh, let me just, uh, uh, as I told,
uh, that we, we, we are going to follow this, uh, sequence
of, in which we are going
to build up our knowledge about the RNN.
So what we'll do is in the, in the next class, I'll see
how much I can cover today,
but the next class we'll try to understand the RNN and, uh,
after RNN maybe first we'll understand types of RNN,
and then we'll understand back propagation in the RNN
and what is the problem with the RNN itself.
Then L-S-T-M-G-R-U, we solve that problem of the RNN,
then deep RNN bidirectional, RNN,
and then it takes us to the sequence to sequence modeling.
So this, these are all the things which we have planned
to cover in the RNN before going into the next part
and seeing that, okay, how the RNN solves all these problem,
let me stop here to first understand, realize that, okay,
why a new kind of architecture is required
to process the sequence sequential data.
Why not a NN, okay?
And similar, uh, similar argument can be there,
a similar kind of discussion we can do even
with the CNN as well.
But here, uh, CNN, we have seen that for the, uh,
for the image, it works really well.
But, uh, what will, what will happen when we apply the, uh,
sequential like text data for the CN?
Okay? What, what is the process?
What is and cons, but suppose we compare here with the RNN,
these are all the problems, and hence we say that oh,
and a NN is not a good network
for the sequential data like text.
So let me know whether you have understood this
particular part or not.
So why, if we understand, then we can easily understand
what, okay, what is the RNN
or how does it solve all these problems?
So one by one I'll explain you,
how does it solve all these problems?
So before going there,
let me just ask you if you have any questions.
Yes, sir. Uh, so it, uh, was good explanation.
We were able to understand also, sir, so what is the benefit
of share sharing parameter across?
So I was just explaining this, this point, say
that you have, uh, uh, the total num, uh,
a like a, somehow you control the number
of inputs so that whether it is a five input, 10 input,
or hundred input or words in a sentence doesn't matter.
I'll handle it. Okay?
Just, just for the example,
but suppose there is a, there is a sentence
where you have a hundred inputs
and each input is represented by the vocabulary size.
So a hundred into 1000 will be one lack.
So in that case, what will happen that your inputs,
which is one lack inputs, are connected
with three neurons only in the next layer,
only three neurons.
How many parameters you
require in the fairly connected network?
A hundred, sorry, one lag into three, three lag.
That is what I was telling. Now, this is the case
where you have the maximum length a hundred,
but suppose you have 200, uh, uh, uh,
maximum length in a sentence.
Suppose there is a sentence which come
where you have 200 words, okay?
In that case, what will happen?
The 200 in two 1000, first of all, okay?
And 200 into 1000 into three.
Suppose you have 500 length
sentence rather than sentence, I'll say paragraph.
Then what will happen? 500 into 1000 into three.
So that is the number of parameter
what you require every time when you'll feed
your sentence here.
So what is happening, the number
of parameters here is depending on your sequence length,
number of parameters, somehow
is depending on your sequence length.
Okay? Now, this is where, and this is, this is growing.
It's like, if it is controllable, then there is no problem.
Somehow we could have the,
we could have trained our network,
but then what I say with the RNN, we can,
we can handle any length of any length of data, any length
of text, any length.
When I say the upper limit is in finite, you know,
then I can't be ha growing this number of parameter
because these number of parameters here are directly
depending on my sequence length.
So somehow we have to come up with a way so that we can
share these parameters between input and input
and, uh, the next hidden layer, whatever,
uh, neurons we have.
So this is where we'll, uh, do some things such
that some parameters are shared.
Some rather than just, uh, just increasing the number of,
number of parameters for, uh,
as thin input length will, will, will increase.
Okay? We'll see that the architecture,
then it'll be more clear.
Oh, yes, thank you, sir.
What exactly is this vocabulary size?
Uh, is it depending on sentence length
or how it is, how it is decided, sir?
So suppose here,
suppose this is my corpus, this is my data,
Okay? In this
data, how many words we have?
We study ML
3, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 5, 3, 8, 8, 5, 13, 13,
and four.
17. 17. Total number of words we have altogether.
But if you see here,
there are some words which are repeating like we is
repeating here, study studies, repeating.
Here we is here also.
So if you'll see that one in this whole corpus,
there are some unique words we have, okay?
And there are some words which are repeating in the first
sentence, second sentence, maybe
in the same sentence, same words.
So vocabulary is the unique words
or unique tokens, whatever you say,
available in the whole corpus.
So out of 17, all seventeens are not, are not unique, right?
I, I clearly see that 1, 2, 3, 3 times V is coming.
So from 17 you can subtract two
because v appearance will be only once.
So 15 study is coming two times.
So study, you have to count only once.
So, uh, 17 minus three is 14 ML is unique.
Rn, LLM class is unique today,
neural network, maybe everything.
So 14 out of 17, 14 is the vocabulary.
That is how you calculate.
So vocabulary, nothing but the unique tokens in your corpus.
Okay? Okay. Unique number of tokens. Okay, fine.
Yeah. Now, so what we do, uh,
while representing each word, Azure, one hot vector, we see
that, okay, how many, because one
hot vector, how do we build?
Yeah. So we, we place every word
or any every unique word in my column
and every unique word in my role also.
And wherever that word is matching there, I place one.
So if I don't have all the unique word in row
and column where I'll place one for that particular word,
one hot vector, right?
That's why we need that vocabulary size as the length
of my one hot vector. Yeah.
Meaning sir, from, uh, one hot encoding process, uh,
we are going to ignore those, uh, repeating, uh, words.
No, no, it's not one hot.
In general, uh, in general,
you don't want redundant information, right?
Okay. It suppose we is coming here
or we is coming here, we had the same meaning. Okay?
Correct. So when I create a vector for V
it should not change based on my sentence
or based on how many times it has come in a sentence
or based on which position in height, test
sentence, anywhere it'll come. We have the same meaning,
Correct?
That is what I'm trying to encode.
That's why, uh, for each unique token,
I have a unique vector, which is representing
that particular token.
Got it? Got it. Thank you. Okay,
Others query, Sir?
Um, so, uh, if I understand this correctly,
we're using, um, uh, we wanna have go
with the RNN architecture for sequence
sequential information or sequential data and, um,
and general field, forward network style for, um, uh,
for general, let's say
Tablet data.
But for example, if you take, uh,
if you take some time series data that may have, um, uh,
fixed, um, fixed structure, for example, if you,
I'm just giving you example of for sensor data, right?
So, um, just, just throwing some example,
like if you are recording temperature, treasure,
and precipitation, et cetera.
Mm-hmm. Um, each of these may have a sequence in each zone.
Let's say the temperature of morning can influence afternoon
and afternoon can influence.
Mm-hmm. Uh, let's say the temperature
around in that cycle, right?
Correct. Correct. And, um, but,
but there is a tabular structure around it.
So which one would you prefer, uh,
for these kind of data?
Obviously sequence.
If sequence, see by any means, if you see the sequence,
we have to go with that.
Otherwise, you will simply lose that meaning and sequence.
If you, you lose the sequence, it'll, it doesn't have any,
any, any, uh, context, uh, left, right?
So if you see that, see the data, what we represent
as a table, it's not like it is, it is always a tabler data
like this, this text also I have represented here
as a table, but it doesn't mean that it is a tabler data,
it is a sequential data, right?
So sequence is more important for me when I say traveler, i,
I means, I meant that,
that each features in the tables are independent.
They don't depend on each other,
but that is not the case here.
So in your case, also when you have the morning temperature,
afternoon temperature, evening temperature,
okay, makes sense.
So yeah, sequence is more important.
Okay. And one more, one more question, sir.
I think the, it's about the wording here.
You're using a NN, um, instead of ff and n
Ah, correct, correct, correct.
A n when I say it is a feed forward, I mean,
it's a fully connected network, not feed forward.
Mm-hmm. And feed forward and back propagation, uh, together.
I say a NNA fully connected network.
It is where every inputs are connected
with every other inputs.
Uh, the, the vanilla neural neural network, the a NN.
Okay, that is what I'm talking about. Yeah.
Thank you, sir. Yes,
Sir. Uh,
a small request, uh, previous class continuation, sir.
Loading, pre-trained VGG 16, that coding.
Could you please? Uh,
Oh, I did not explain in the last class
I had explained right theory,
It was done.
Oh, I did not explain the code.
Code. No sir. I was,
I missed that, but maybe in the next
class, we'll see that first.
Okay. And then I'll take you
to the next concept of RN first.
We'll see that demo itself. No problem. Thank you,
Sir. Thank you,
Sir. Even the link is
not given of that demo.
Thank is not given. At least I couldn't see in
that, uh, slide.
No, no, it must be, so these are not clickable slides also,
sir, because we have to read from the LMS,
we don't get PDFs anymore.
Oh, but then it is, it link, you can click now
and if it is there in the slide, sir,
I could not see all that.
I just check that.
So transfer learning,
this is the slide which I uploaded, and there is a link.
Okay, sir. Uh, please check that. See this link?
Is there what you see here? Yeah,
Yeah, I see sir, there
In the, in the last slide. You see the
Last slide? Yeah, sir.
Okay. Yeah. Thank you. Thank you,
Sir. I have a couple of
queries. Uh, yeah, please, please.
So for the first one, it's regarding the assignment.
So we have the liberty to use the GPU, right?
Yeah. You can use it, no problem. Yeah.
Okay. And the second question is, uh, regarding the, uh,
mid-semester examination.
So there was one question.
Can I put the question in the chat box, sir?
Uh, yeah. Tell me what is the question?
I, I have not seen that. So that I, it'll take some time.
Uh, okay. Just let, let me know what was the query? Yeah,
So we were given the wait, uh, DK and, uh, the weight.
Uh, we were asked to calculate the L two penalty
contribution, uh, to the loss.
So there are two methods to it.
So one is the LW square, uh, which is,
and the other one is the LW square by two,
when we consider the differentiation.
Mm-hmm. So, um, we were instructed
to consider the differentiation one.
That means LW square by two is the formula.
Okay. So by that, uh, the answer should be zero point,
uh, 0, 0, 0 2, but the correct answer,
No problem. Lemme do one
thing. Uh, uh, yeah, Linda, you just mail me.
I mean, put mail to me.
I put me in cc, whatever, ah, uh, those questions,
you can mail us together
because I have not seen the questions, uh, clearly.
I'll have to see the questions.
We'll review it and we'll get back to you.
I, I already, sir, do You want mail
On Saturday itself?
Then we'll look into that. Maybe next class.
I will tell you what is
Say sir. I, uh,
sir, I have seen that question, sir. Mm.
For her mail also have checked. Mm.
I'll, uh, check the quiz question with ma'am
and I'll, uh, put the, what the query she have told.
No, I'll receive that
One. Yeah, please, please discuss
with me also maybe tomorrow.
Tomorrow, yes sir. Yes sir. Yes sir. Bye.
Sir. I have one more question.
This is a theoretical question. I'm just curious.
So for the MNAs data set mm-hmm.
Uh, we were asked to experiment, uh, the, uh,
experimented comparing the F-N-N-F-F-N-N
and convolution neural network
and check the parameter reduction.
Mm-hmm. So I did some, uh, architecture
and then I calculated the things.
I got a CNN, uh, approximately two, 2.7 times less,
or, I mean,
have fewer parameters than a feedforward neural network.
But, um, when we consider different architecture, uh,
like some of, uh, my classmates did,
so they got 10 times fewer parameters.
So how does it vary, sir?
I mean, was there any, uh, option?
This is a, uh, question from quiz.
Ah, yes. Uh, just please send me,
let me ha let me see the questions,
then I will be able to answer.
Yes, there is, the parameters vary from the a n mm-hmm.
But that variation should not be for the same network,
should not be someone is getting 10 times less.
Someone is getting, uh, seven times later.
That should not be there for the same time.
Yes. That, I'll look into that. What is there?
We'll discuss that, no problem.
Sure, sir. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Bye. Thank you, sir. That's all I have.
Okay. Alright then.
So let us, uh, I'll share the slide,
what we have done till today for, from this a n part,
and we'll continue in the next class. Right? Thank you.
Yes, sir. Thank you, sir. Sir,
Thank you, sir.
Thank.